I don't want to enter I think that
American command vehicles did too much
on joking despising on Sarah Palin
sometimes in a sexist way in a majesty a
in an unpalatable correct way and this
was a mistake you though those who did
that did not harm her I think that on
the contrary they they helped her so I
would not enter in that I would just say
that she has a terrible politics that
she embodies the worst of the
conservatives in America that if I don't
think it will happen by the way but if
she were to be vice president or
president who knows I think that we will
all regret the neoconservatives who
compared to her our extreme leftist
extreme liberals know Sarah my concern
with Sarah Palin is that she really
believes that the dinosaurs dinosaurs
our contemporary news of Moses and and
so on she really believed that Noah and
the Ark of Noah went down the Grand
Canyon a few thousand years ago he
really believed that and that there you
have some pieces of the ark that you can
see from Erik apparently she would
really believe that in the highs in the
scores of young Americans boys and girls
learn how to become a citizen should be
teach should be taught equal a science
which is Darwinism and Kruk theory which
is creationism what she says about
wearing weapons and so on and what it
means for me and I and I'm sure for
majority of Americans he just and
durable but it is not Sarah Palin it is
what she embodies so the advice I would
if I dare I'm not American I have not to
give it a listen to anybody but if I was
an adversary of Sarah Palin in America I
would probably stop with the sexist
match East middle middle America jokes
which are unappropriate and I would
target on politics the result of that is
yesterday when you had when you had
console far you know Hubert commentators
politics so far in despising in
despising her in an uncorrectable is in
front of her he does not even dare to
attack from the real grounds that is a
that is a bad deal bad deal attacking
under the belt and being unable to
attack the brain that the worst politics